I I cite them something I wrote a New  York Times survey of experts quote  unquote which usually means foolish  people who know one thing  and uh the the whole heading was our our  fathers necessary it was actually a a  big column uh in the New York Times and  and repeatedly that fathers are not  necessary again the secular intellectual  is is generally a stupid person  fathers are essential everything you  read proves it and yet we we live  in a world that denies the obvious  that's a good phrase for the Modern Age  the the denial of the obvious  girls without fathers in their lives are  far more promiscuous and you may say so  what  and the answer to the show what is well  there is a what the what is they get  more depressed  they they get angrier they're less  they're less happy